the u.s dollar has been the global
reserve currency for you know 100 plus
years whatever it's been and
if that changes even if it's hey it's
still the global it's still the uh
western hemisphere reserve currency
but is now an eastern hemisphere reserve
currency and you do get two or more
different worlds
it changes the game a lot
right it does you two are looking at me
like actually
right there though that is that is the
changing world order and i mean it's not
this scenario per se but this i mean
this has been written about a lot like
ray dalio's book which is called the
changing world order it talks about you
know the there's a declining um like
current
superpower um and then there's this
ascending power right now right now that
one is uh china and if you look back
over history you can kind of see these
cycles and how these reserve currencies
the country with that reserve currency
status it changes over time so it's a
cycle i think ray's wrong you think he's
wrong i think he's wrong um not in his
analysis of how the world uh operates
and not in his analysis of uh the fact
that there is transitions between these
but i think that uh he
is looking within a smaller box than
actually the full aperture of the the uh
game board if you will and he's looking
just at country verse country and i
think the part that he's missing is that
the ascending currency is not attached
to a country so he's looking at it as if
the u.s dollar and the u.s economy
falters then oh china is going to go and
overtake them
nope
they are all going to be disrupted if
the contrarian thing that's different
right in terms of innovation and
disruption you have to do something
different and be right now if you do
something different and you're wrong
then you're just an idiot right but if
you do something different and you're
right that's where true disruption
innovation happens and rey is only
looking at the fiat currency system he's
only looking at the legacy economic
system
in 13 years
we now have the equivalent of 50 of the
u.s uh population
using a new currency that didn't exist
13 years ago 150 plus million people use
bitcoin and some of them will use it
or they have it
having it is using it right the majority
of use of the us dollar is simply to
hold it and i don't know exactly what
the date uh what all the data is but if
you go and you look just think of the uh
the money that the average citizen has
right
most of it most of the time and most of
the things that they do is they just
hold the currency they may invest it
they may buy things but if you look on a
month-to-month basis right if you have a
thousand dollars in your bank account
and you spend 400 of them
then in that month what'd you do
majority of it was you were just holding
the currency and so holding ends up
being a big piece of it it's a store of
value you're trying to hold the value
now it's a shitty one over a really long
period of time
but i think that's where the analysis
falls down which is not how the world
has worked in the past he nails that
like i've learned so much from him
he also understands that like the u.s
debt to gdp not looking great there's
all these like warning signs when things
start to change that's up for debate
like on a timeline basis
but the threat is not another fiat
currency or another fiat-based economy
not even so much a threat as much as
just like the next phase here is in the
digital world
and what we're watching is like is the
digital economy or the analog economy
bigger now
and the internet
is the internet an american economy
or is it a russian economy or is it a
chinese economy or is it a
it kind of doesn't fit right like people
will say like oh alibaba sales are like
that accounts towards the chinese
government or the chinese gdp and like
sure
okay because that's where most of the
workers are based that's where the
headquarters are all that stuff
what happens when companies are fully
remote
now who gets to claim the gdp now
they'll go well where's the company
incorporated
but
really if you think about that there's
companies that are now growing where
they have immense amount of uh
employees all around the world
and so is that gdp really concentrated
where the company is founded or
incorporated
or is there economic impact in all these
other economies so some people say okay
well let's actually go look on like an
amazon how much of uh the buying and
selling is happening in i don't know
mexico
and they'll say well how do we calculate
what's in mexico uh if the buyer's in
mexico okay but what if the seller's in
america does that count towards the
mexican uh gdp or the american gdp
but you start getting these questions
and you're like it's not as clear-cut
people will come up with definitions
they will come up with a way to
calculate it but it's just not as
obvious as it used to be because the
friction has gone down so much and so i
just think that the big like out of left
field disruption is
we have a brand new currency
that 150 million people have adopted
and right now they're actually using it
as a not as a replacement they're using
it as augmentation
but if billions of people around the
world augment
their fiat currency with a like a
savings tool
i mean that's pretty crazy to me